allez
bienvenue dans parlement hebdo votre
rendez vous d'info du week-end retour en
45 minutes sur les temps forts qui ont
marqué la semaine politique une folle
semaine marquée à l'assemblée par
l'examen du projet de loi de
modernisation de l'économie au sénat par
la sempiternelle réforme des
institutions sans oublier bien sûr la
sphère du mariage annulé qui a quelque
peu gâcher l'existence de la garde des
sceaux rachida dati
autant d'événements sur lesquels perrine
nous attendons l'avis et les
observations film de notre invité de la
semaine tous et en tant que porte parole
du parti socialiste bruno le roux
bonjour vous avez forcément un avis sur
tout je rappelle également que vous êtes
député socialiste de la seine saint
denis
vous avez donc la lourde tâche chaque
semaine de porter la parole socialiste
qui comme chacun sait est une et
indivisible
vous êtes également en charge au sein du
parti des investitures pour les
élections là c'est une occasion pour
vous c'est un poste clé en tout cas pour
ce faire pas mal d'amis voire parfois
sans doute aussi des ennemis
et puis pour vous situer un petit peu
dans la galaxie socialiste en ce moment
vous êtes un proche de françois hollande
alors on semble effectivement nous
allons passer en revue toute l'actualité
de la semaine et on commence bien sûr
par la journée de lundi
et trois lettres ont dominé la semaine à
l'assemblée nationale elle est mieux
pour loi de modernisation de l'économie
un texte dont l'examen a commencé lundi
un texte un peu hétéroclite qui aborde
différents sujets simplification de la
vie des entrepreneurs haut débit livret
a et surtout surtout le nerf de la
guerre
l'assouplissement des conditions
d'installation des grandes surfaces
un sujet qui déplaît à la gauche mais
aussi à une partie de la droite aussi
françois fillon at il tout faire en
début de semaine pour déminer tout de
suite le rappel des faits avec céline
bittner c'est un texte à haut risque
pour la majorité
la preuve dans l'hémicycle le
gouvernement fait bloc pas moins de 5
min sont venus soutenir le texte
objectif éviter un nouveau couac ce
matin encore françois fillon réunit les
membres de la majorité pour trouver un
accord sur le point qui fâche
l'assouplissement des conditions
d'installation des grandes surfaces les
députés ump craignent pour l'avenir du
petit commerce
un compromis a finalement été trouvé
l'accord consiste à faire en sorte que
dans six mois on aura un texte pour
introduire dans le code de l'urbanisme
tout ce qu'est l'urbanisme commercial
et on a aussi un accord sur quatre
points deux périodes transitoires et qui
permet au maire
réagir si il juge nécessaire
en clair le gouvernement ne bouge pas
sur le principe d'une plus grande
liberté d'installation
désormais seuls les magasins de plus de
1000 mètres carrés devront demander une
autorisation pour s'implanter avant le
seuil était fixé à 300 mètres carrés
mais en contrepartie le maire aura plus
d'autorité un pouvoir d'intervention
renforcée en matière d'urbanisme
commercial
quel est le maire qui peut se
désintéresser de chez dante de ses
entrées de ville
aucun or vous savez bien ce qu'il est
advenu au fil des vingt dernières années
où les trente dernières années
concernant les entrées de ville avec ses
immenses parkings si vous voulez
confirmant les installations
commerciales
si le gouvernement a réussi à apaiser
les inquiétudes de la majorité il doit
encore faire face à une opposition très
remontée
pour le parti socialiste ce texte est
fait pour contenter les grandes
enseignes
rien de plus il ya eu un accord
préalable entre par exemple michel
edouard leclerc les prisons d'une
république qui s'en était pas caché en
commission ils avaient expliqué que le
prochain texte chatel il y en a toutes
les trois semaines non j'exagère il y en
a un tous les trois ou quatre mois
prochain texte chatel traiterait de la
négociabilité aujourd'hui il a obtenu ce
qu'il voulait c'est à dire que on va
pouvoir passer moi l'expression un peu
vulgaire serrer le kiki aux fournisseurs
sans qu'il puisse avoir le droit de
râler
le débat sur le projet de loi de
modernisation de l'économie s'annonce où
l'on est tendue nous 500 amendements ont
été déposés sur ce texte 44 articles
sont ces doper la croissance et créer de
nouveaux emplois
en prenant le risque sur ce sujet là
encore on n'est pas dans une espèce de
position un peu manichéenne entre la
droite qui parle flexibilité économique
et la gauche qui donne le sentiment de
ne pas vouloir toucher à l'existant dans
deux dimensions d'abord la première est
le mot n'a pas été repris alors que
c'était le fer de lance du gouvernement
il y encore quelques jours vous n'avez
pas employer une seule fois dans ce
reportage
le mot pouvoir d'achat or on nous
vendait ce texte il y a encore quelques
jours comme un texte censé susciter de
la croissance supplémentaire et donc du
pouvoir d'achat pour les français et on
voit bien récit de la garde en a reparlé
lors la discussion générale armée mais
aujourd'hui on perd 0,3 pour ça on sait
très bien qu'on est uniquement on est
uniquement là dans des intentions et que
ce texte n'est pas une loi de
modernisation parce que si les mots ont
un sens et la modernisation ne veut pas
dire grand
chose alors il faudrait assumer très
clairement ce qu'est ce texte pour
savoir où sont les désaccords entre la
droite et la gauche
c'est une loi de dérégulation de
l'économie c'est une loi de
déréglementation il y à une succession
d'articles très importants les uns après
les autres sur l'organisation de la
concurrence sur l'organisation même de
notre droit du travail sur la question
de l'activité salariée du statut
d'entrepreneur
c'est un texte très discret gardez-vous
rejeté tout en bloc sur ce tacle
autorités de la concurrence
car s'il ya un problème en france et le
gouvernement peut toujours dire
aujourd'hui nous voulons faciliter
l'installation des moyennes surfaces
mais aujourd'hui il ya une telle
concentration de la grande distribution
dans notre pays qu'à la différence de
l'allemagne quand la ministre fait le
tour et va constater en allemagne que le
panier de la ménagère est moins cher
c'est tout simplement parce que en
allemagne il a une forme de concurrence
beaucoup plus forte et que ceux qui
vendent les magasins elle mettait le
principe de plus de concurrence mais pas
de la manière dont s'est pratiqué par la
majorité la concurrence n'existe pas
aujourd'hui dans notre pays
l espagne est dérégulé compléter ce que
je retiens dans ce texte c'est la
nécessité de mise en place d'une
autorité de la concurrence
je pense qu'elle aura beaucoup de
travail dans notre pays parce qu'il ya
beaucoup trop d'entente
je regrette que ce texte met les
centres-villes à mal sans qu'il y ait de
possibilités de véritable croissance et
surtout il va y avoir les précieuses 1
le rôle du maire est aujourd'hui vous
savez sous pression quand il a
aujourd'hui des demandes qui sont des
demandes faites par la grande
distribution
il est souvent difficile d'y résister
mais j'ai surtout peur pour les petits
industriels et pour les agriculteurs de
notre pays qui risquent beaucoup
souffrir dans ce qui va leur être
demandés dans les mois prochains
allez la suite lundi alors que la
prochaine mobilisation dans la fonction
publique est prévue pour mardi prochain
le 10 juin
nicolas sarkozy a cherché cette semaine
à convaincre les enseignants des biens
fondés et de ses réformes dans
l'éducation nationale
lundi il recevait donc à l'elysée les
présidents d'université les recteurs les
inspecteurs d'académie pour leur exposer
sa vision sa vision du lycée de demain
une réforme notamment sur les filières
devrait voir le jour pour la rentrée
2009 une réforme qui inclut aussi une
refonte de la formation des enseignants
et là sur ce point le consensus est loin
d'être acquis nicolas béart après la
réforme du lycée de xavier darcos
nicolas sarkozy s'attaque à la formation
des enseignants
et c'est pour cela que nous avons décidé
avec xavier darcos que les différents
concours professeurs des écoles capes
agrégation soit intégrée au cursus
universitaire et soit ouvert à tous
titulaires au futur titulaire d'un
master 2 en échange de cette année
d'études supplémentaires eh bien nous
nous engageons à ce que les débuts de
carrière soit revalorisé première
modification dès 2010 pour devenir
enseignant il faudra désormais titulaire
d'un master soit cinq ans d'études
contre trois actuellement
koller a besoin de réformes elle a
surtout besoin d'une ambition d'un
projet et de l'adhésion des professeurs
je suis inquiet de la méthode qui est
utilisé aujourd'hui parce que justement
elle n'a pas l'adhésion des professeurs
un niveau d'exigence plus élevé qui va
permettre une revalorisation des
premiers salaires des enseignants
aujourd'hui un professeur gagne 1,3 fois
le smic en début de carrière
la réforme doit s'appliquer dès
septembre 2010 l'éducation nationale
envisage de supprimer 24 mille postes de
fonctionnaires stagiaires
mais voilà du côté des syndicats
l'accueil est plutôt mitigé on regrette
notamment la disparition des iufm mais
aussi le manque de professionnalisation
des masters on risque d' instituer une
coupure entre les recrutés au niveau
master nettement mieux payés et sans
doute bien moins bien formés et vie
celles et ceux qui feront tourner la
maison depuis des années et qui risque
d'avoir des niveaux de rémunération
inférieure
jeudi nicolas sarkozy doit effectuer un
déplacement dans une école un livre
blanc avec l'ensemble de ses
propositions sera également soumis avant
l'été par le ministère de l'éducation
nationale
voilà donc un reportage nicolas vert et
charlotte riez i alors bruno le roux
mieux vaut des profs bien dans le métier
c'est à dire bien formés bien payés
plutôt que trop nombreux pourquoi je ne
pose pas un à l'autre quelle est
aujourd'hui la ligne le fil rouge du
gouvernement faire des économies
budgétaires dans tous les ministères et
cats ont trouvé sur l'éducation
nationale là dans la formation des
enseignants
l'idée de se dire on va supprimer 24
mille postes de fonctionnaires
stagiaires
il y avait des spécificités dans le
système français qui faisait que l'on
étudié trois ans et qu'ensuite on
devenait fonctionnaires stagiaires c'est
à dire que sa formation on
la cumuler ensuite au contact de la
classe avec un rapport aux élèves une
pédagogie acquise alors que là
maintenant on va faire cinq ans et
ensuite on choisit de ne rentrer ou de
ne pas rentrer d'ailleurs dans la
fonction publique et notamment dans
l'éducation nationale et autres la
question de la mixité
lorsque vous le savez que plus on va
loin dans les études et - iliad mixité
sociale
se pose aussi la question de ce qu'est
ce qu'on ne va pas tarir la source de ce
qu'ils veulent avoir vocation demain à
aller dans le secteur de l'éducation
nationale dans une logique quantitative
ya aucun qualitatif il ya comme choses
qui sont tentait beaucoup en ce moment
de l'élection nationale le qualitatif ce
que je souhaiterais c'est que depuis
maintenant plus de trois mois il y à des
réformes qui s'annoncent aient tous les
quinze jours sans aucune concertation
s'il y avait véritablement une envie
qualitative moi je fais confiance à ceux
qui sont les partenaires de la
communauté éducative pour le reconnaître
et donc la méthode même du gouvernement
me pose problème ce genre difficile en
un temps de bouger de faire bouger dans
l'éducation c'est pas difficile vous
serez nouvelle dynamique c'est pas
difficile de faire les concertations
c'est pas difficile d'afficher une
ambition est de mettre sur la table
moi je ne m'explique pas comment depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois
toutes les réformes par exemple est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une avancée
quand on réduit de deux heures par
semaine le temps d'enseignement en école
primaire
non ça se place dans un contexte
d'économies budgétaires pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait moins d'heures
travaillées à l'école et donc je le dis
cette réforme est aujourd'hui vu par le
petit bout de la lorgnette et je
souhaiterais qu'il y ait une véritable
concertation dans l'éducation parce
qu'on parle quand même de l'avenir de
notre pays
allez la journée de mardi maintenant
avec les députés qui votent la réforme
des institutions
effectivement péril c'était le vote de
la semaine le vote en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale de la réforme
hautement polémique des institutions
après moult tergiversations la gauche
dans son ensemble a finalement voté
contre le texte
même si le ps continue d'expliquer que
les jeux ne sont pas faits pour le
congrès de juillet prochain tout de
suite le récit de ce vote avec chloé
buffard jusqu'au dernier moment françois
fillon tente de convaincre les
socialistes
sans cet amendement adopté dont une
vingtaine déposée par l'opposition le
gouvernement par exemple accepté le
principe d'un référendum d'initiative
populaire
le premier ministre demande donc à la
gauche de faire un effort jeudi à
l'opposition que la cohérence voudrait
que cet esprit d'union se manifestent
jusqu'au bout parce qu'on ne peut pas
d'une main enrichir le contenu d'un
texte et de l'autre main voter contre sa
mise en oeuvre
mais pour les socialistes le compte n'y
est pas la majorité a refusé la réforme
du sénat
refuser encore la fiabilisation du temps
de parole du chef de l'état en première
lecture ce sera donc non un nom en forme
d'attentes notre vote n'est ni figé ni
définitif nous allons évaluer au sénat
puis en deuxième lecture les avancées et
les reculs qui vont s'opérer
notre seule boussole c'est l' envie de
faire évoluer notre démocratie un
non-socialiste unitaire qu'un même les
députés qui se disait prêt à voter la
réforme dans une tribune du monde ont
voté contre
c'est parce qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
positions du groupe parce que nous
n'avions pas débattue parce que nous
n'avions pas arrêter notre position
majoritairement que nous nous sommes
librement exprimée le groupe ayant
décidé de voter non en première lecture
je voterai non mais vraiment sans aucun
problème cet après midi côté ump c'est
un large louis seule une dizaine de
députés souverainistes ou villepinistes
ont voté contre
c'est aussi oui pour le nouveau centre
mais plus timides certains se sont même
abstenue pour les centristes
le texte doit être améliorée notamment
sur la question de la limitation du
droit d'amendement
quant aux verts et aux communistes ils
ont voté contre la réforme
sans surprise il estime qu'elle ne va
pas assez loin en matière de droits de
l'opposition du ministre pour 315 contre
231 malgré l'opposition de la gauche la
réforme est votée mais le nom du ps rend
incertain son adoption lors du congrès
de versailles
car le gouvernement aura besoin des
trois cinquièmes des suffrages exprimés
et prochain étape pour ce projet de loi
constitutionnelle sur les institutions
et bien l'examen bien sûr par le sénat
ce sera à partir du 17 juin les
sénateurs d'ailleurs entendent bien
imprimer leur marque sur ce texte
donc on peut s'attendre à de nouveaux
amendements de la part de l'opposition
bien sûr mais aussi de la majorité
plusieurs points en effet ne font pas
l'unanimité à droite comme par exemple
la limitation du 49-3 ou la suppression
du référendum automatique pour tout
nouvel entrant dans l'union européenne
à part bien sûr pour la turquie pierre
bonne chose est défendue par nicolas
sarkozy inspiré des travaux d'edouard
balladur c'est un texte largement
modifié par les députés qui arrivera au
sénat le 17 juin
à commencer par l'article 1er qui
reconnaît désormais les langues
régionales la langue française pour nous
et que la chose de primordial
je comprends pas qu'on essaie de mettre
d'autres dans la france s est l'unité de
la république c'est comme ça qu'elle a
été créée et pour les france et
l'étranger c'est plus qu'important
on a déjà mis suffisamment le temps à
réaliser l'unité nationale et le
français pour tout ce qui est que c'est
peut-être prendre un risque que d'ouvrir
cette possibilité donc le sujet
n'est pas tranchée trois pages plus loin
autre modification autre article
l'article 11 qui inscrit la parité
hommes femmes dans la constitution
les avis divergent même chez les
sénatrices est-ce que ça doit figurer
dans la constitution
encore une fois je vous dis la
constitution est bien fait et je pense
que la constitution ne doit pas être
trop bavarde
l'amendement de madame zimmermann et
bien en même temps j'ai quelques
méfiances parce que l'égalité elle est
déjà à d'ores et déjà inscrits et on
voit où on en est aujourd'hui en matière
d d'inégalités mais c'est l'article 33
qui concentre les attaques gauche et
droite unie contre l'obligation de
recourir au référendum pour l'adhésion
de la turquie que c'est un amendement
qui mérite d'être je n'irai pas amendé
mais tout simplement supprimée c'est de
revenir à la position initiale et pas de
référendum puisqu'il ya d'autres
possibilités pour l'état français pour
le président mais aussi pour le
parlement de refuser un pays
en tout cas son entrée dans l'union
européenne est-ce inadmissible d'avoir
un dans la constitution en droit qui
s'applique visiblement à un pays
en tout cas à l'échelle de historique à
un seul pays qui demandent à entrer dans
l'europe c'est absolument impossible
l'examen du texte risque d'être plus
compliqué au sénat qu'à l'assemblée
edouard balladur en personne a fait le
déplacement auprès du groupe ump pour
faire dit on de la pédagogie
alors bruno le roux on a entendu tout à
l'heure jean marc ayrault dire dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée que le vote
des socialistes n'était pas figé
qu'est-ce qui peut encore le faire
évoluer évoluer bien sûr vers un oui à
cette réforme des institutions je vais
vous dire les choses clairement
dans ce texte le président de la
république n'était intéressé que par une
chose venir devant le congrès cela a été
mis en place
cela ne me pose pas de problème si cela
reste dans le texte nous l'accepterons
par contre ce que nous souhaitons c'est
qu'il puisse y avoir dans les prochaines
lectures avancé sur le mode de scrutin
sénatorial
je ne reviens pas sur la démonstration
seule assemblée à n'avoir jamais connu
d'alternance dans notre pays nous
voulons qu'il y ait une avancée sur la
comptabilisation des tentes d'expression
politique
les choses peuvent avancer la presse que
nous l'avons compris et nous voulons
qu'il y ait une
avancez sur le droit de vote des
étrangers aux élections locales qui
était un des engagements du président de
la république et donc s'il y a ceux là à
ce moment là nous ne ferons pas un
problème de ce qui était pour nous
pourtant quelque chose que nous ne
voulions pas l'expression du président
devant le parlement d'un package global
il faut que le gouvernement accepte
l'ensemble de ces conditions est-ce que
s'il ya une ou de ces conditions qu'il
faut pas ça peut suffire ce texte
socialiste pour que ce texte ait de
l'ambition il faut qu'il y ait des
avancées on ne parle pas d'un petit
texte pour l'instant il n'y a que peu
d'avancé dans ce texte il ya même un
recul profond la limitation du droit
d'amendement à l'assemblée nationale
parce que on nous dit quelquefois qu'il
y à de l'obstruction à l'assemblée
nationale mais quand la majorité de
gauche dans ce pays et que le sénat ait
le pouvoir de blocage
non ne parle pas d'obstruction c'est
quelque chose qui semble normal
aujourd'hui à la droite et donc il ne
peut pas y avoir limitation du droit
d'amendement il doit y avoir réforme du
sénat droit de vote des étrangers
comptabilisation des temps et là nous
serons dans une réforme profonde de
notre démocratie
hélas le président pourra venir s'il le
veut s'exprimer devant nous verrons si
l'avenir vous donne raison ou pas
revendre et maintenant bruno le roux sur
l'autre sujet épineux de la semaine la
sphère qui a quelque peu gâché la
semaine de la garde des sceaux mardi en
effet rachida dati a dû s'expliquer à
l'assemblée nationale sur sa tardive
décision de faire appel du jugement vous
en souvenez qui a annulé un mariage pour
cause de mensonges sur la virginité à 2
les pouces
la ministre de la justice qui s'est un
peu lâché à l'occasion de cette séance
de questions au gouvernement
une drôle d'ambiance dans l'hémicycle
que nous raconte anaïs combattions les
socialistes interroge rachida dati sur
une question qui divise à droite
notamment quelles instructions comptez
vous donner ce jugement d'appel confirme
la décision du tribunal de lille
êtes vous prête à déposer un projet de
loi qui met fin à toute ambiguïté
la garde des sceaux ne répond pas
directement mais sur un ton polémique se
laissant envahir par l'émotion
où étiez vous lorsque vous avez créé
et la politique des grands faire quand
vous avez abandonné un nombre de jeunes
filles dans ces quartiers difficiles
entre les mains des grands frères la
politique des grands princes et vous
alors vous pouvez attaquer la garde des
sceaux
vous pouvez m'attaquerai mais j'ai
échappé à l'échec de votre politique
qu'est ce qui vous dérange
alors si
deux graves n'empêchait pas ses jeunes
filles d'être libre ne les empêchait pas
d'être libre semaine difficile pour
rachida dati après avoir été critiqué
notamment sur sa discrétion pendant la
réforme des institutions et sur sa
première réaction face à l'annulation du
mariage par le tribunal de lille sa
meilleure défense et donc la tacc elle
s'en prend à la politique d'intégration
de la gauche
pour les socialistes le problème est
évidemment ailleurs le problème c'est
pas la politique d'intégration des
socialistes le problème c'est la
compétence du garde des sceaux et quand
le garde des sceaux se met à approuver
les décisions qui sont inacceptables qui
touche à toutes les valeurs de la
république qui touche aussi au droit
avant de se déjuger sous la pression la
chancellerie le problème c'est que fait
madame dati dans un gouvernement
pour vous accepter de rentrer dans un
gouvernement j'ai envie de dire ces
points de brouillard et pour le pire
mais sera une référence un peu idiotes
aujourd'hui c'est quand même pour
assumer des situations lourde et vous
n'êtes pas là pour être adulé pour
sortir le soir pour ben boudreau pour
alors en voyage c'est pas du show
business et c'est pas du people c'est
difficile sur les bancs de l'ump les
avis sont partagés
et dans les couloirs du palais bourbon
les députés de la majorité ne se
bousculait pas pour défendre la garde
des sceaux
alors on a quand même senti que les
masques tombent et un peu mardi jusqu'à
présent même la gauche s'était montrée
très généreuse vis-à-vis de rachida dati
aussi parce qu'elles ont le sel c'est un
symbole de l'intégration à la française
on a senti en maintenant que tout cela
est derrière vous qu'aujourd'hui vous
assumez de vous lâcher un peu on passe
peut-être de la fascination au lynchage
ce n'est pas ça nous avons posé une
question à rachida dati parce qu'il y
avait eu mauvaise expression dès le
début de cette affaire et donc nous lui
donnions une occasion ne voulions pas ne
pas poser la question sur un problème
grave
elle a choisi d'être dans l'agression
sur un sujet où pourtant elle avait été
du début jusqu'à la fin
à côté de la plaque dans sa première
réaction et je dirais même dans sa
décision finale qu'elle fait au nom du
gouvernement parce que la décision
qu'elle prend au final de faire appel de
cette décision est incohérente avec sa
première réaction
mais elle est surtout incohérente avec
la volonté de faire véritablement entre
humains aussi délicat mais vous savez on
a déconseillé quand on est ministre on
ne réagit pas simplement parce qu'on
reçoit un coup de fil et que l'on est
amené à réagir tout de suite quand on
est garde des sceaux ont réagi au nom
d'un gouvernement avec l'idée qu'est la
loi républicaine et donc je pense qu'il
faut se garder de premières réactions et
surtout derrière il ya savoir y revenir
une heure vous avez entendu marylise
lebranchu les propos très durs qu'elle
tenait sur rachida dati vous avez vu
aussi peut-être cette une de l'express
en sept semaines enquête sur les
caprices de la garde des sceaux est ce
que le débat aille vraiment digne et
surtout vraiment je n'ai absolument rien
à faire de ce qu'est en privé ou de ce
que montre rachida dati comme garde des
sceaux
je me borne à constater que depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois en commission
des lois dans l'hémicycle dans la façon
dont elle réagit elle est quelquefois
très légère par rapport à ce qu'est la
fonction même d'un garde des sceaux et
donc qu'elle pourrait faire n'importe
quoi à côté
je n'ai absolument aucun commentaire à
faire ce que je lui demande c'est de
mettre plus d'énergie dans sa fonction
de garde des sceaux et d'assumer la
réalité de cette fonction dans sa
plénitude
elle l'est encore aujourd'hui qu'elle
assume sa fonction allez on poursuit la
semaine avec maintenant les opérations
escargots barrages filtrants et autres
péage gratuit sur les routes de france
tous les jours de cette semaine les
professionnels de la route ont multiplié
les actions coup de poing pour réclamer
un gazole moins cher est un carburant
professionnel européen au même prix pour
tous nicolas béart les a rencontrés pas
moins de 80 poids lourds et plus de 220
km de bouchons partie de gennevilliers
ce matin l'opération escargot des
transporteurs routiers s'est achevée
devant le siège du pétrolier total mode
down on va on va à bussy saint georges
et on sera là même sur perd de l'argent
ça l'a pas ce que vaut mieux perdre de
l'argent que de perte ou le litre de
gazole a augmenté de 25 % depuis janvier
pour pouvoir boucler les fins de mois
les routiers demande un allègement de
leurs charges réclament également un
remboursement immédiat de la détaxe de
la tei pp il sollicite le gouvernement
pour une fixation au niveau européen des
prix des carburants
j'espère très fortement de la présidence
française de l'union européenne on a six
mois pour faire avancer et faire valider
adopté est votée cette question du
gazole professionnel au niveau européen
il faut y arriver
c'est une question de vie ou de mort
pour les entreprises françaises
aujourd'hui le secrétaire d'état aux
transports a promis de présenter un
amendement à la loi sur la modernisation
de l'économie
un amendement qui obligerait les
transporteurs à répercuter la hausse des
prix du carburant sur leurs clients
déraisonnable selon eux enfin quand ça
va nous faire perdre des marchés parce
que les clés et les clients vont aller
voir aller voir ailleurs et ailleurs ils
vont trouver des prix 30% moins cher que
les notes a donc enfin quand ce n'est
pas du tout la bonne solution
c'est donc bien un bras de fer qui a
débuté entre les routiers et le
gouvernement sont nouvelles propositions
d'ici jeudi la profession menace d'un
nouveau mouvement national cette fois ci
et en fin de semaine donc dominique
bussereau a annoncé une série de mesures
en faveur de ce transport routier donc
pour calmer la colère des professionnels
le secrétaire d'état a promis un
étalement du paiement des charges
fiscales et sociales et 1
heureusement anticipé de 100 millions
d'euros au titre du remboursement de la
tpp des mesures qui restent
insuffisantes pour les fédérations de
transport qui restent mobilisés dans le
sens un peu une équation impossible
bruno le roux comment finalement
résoudre les problèmes de ces
professionnels de la route sans
totalement grever le budget de l'état
vous croyez qu'il n'y a que les
problèmes des professionnels à résoudre
moi j'en entends parler tous les jours
par des salariés de ma circonscription
par des gens qui vivent qu'est ce que
vous proposez est le véritable problème
aujourd'hui c'est que le gouvernement
semble insensible à ce qui se passe à
cette hausse
en tout cas il ne réagit pas et dans le
même temps il ne prévoit pas bien là il
y en 2010 sera annoncée des métiers non
il annonce des mesures qui sont des
mesures moi j'étais par exemple frappé
qu'il y ait dans les demandes des
professionnels des mesures qui soient
des mesures particulièrement importantes
pour l'avenir
par exemple le fait qu'il puisse y avoir
aujourd'hui une aide aux changements de
matériels à des matériels qu'ils soient
des matériels propres
or nous savons que nous sommes dans
quelque chose qui n'est pas une crise
conjoncturelle qui est une vraie crise
structurelle et les professionnels ne
s'y trompe pas c'est les fugues plus
faibles qui vont tomber les premiers
vrais proposition audible par ci
sociales sur ces sujets là bien entendu
audible et crédible ont conduit d'abord
dans un premier temps nous avons 10 pour
les salariés parce que je parle en
particulier les salariés nous voulons le
chèque transport tout ça tout de suite
c'est pas un serpent de mer le chèque
restaurant ça marche
le chèque vacances ça marche pourquoi
demain le chèque transport ne marcherait
il pas parce que les salles les
entreprises ne voudrais pas mais il y a
des moyens de les contraindre
aujourd'hui à participer au financement
et à faire en sorte qu'un certain nombre
de supers profits des compagnies mais
plus encore à côté de cela il faut
donner le signe que nous n'allons pas
laisser se créer la fracture énergétique
dans notre pays car c'est les plus
faibles que ce soit les petits
entrepreneurs que ce soit les salariés
les plus modestes qui les plus vites
seront étranglé par cette fracture
énergétique
alors il faut mettre en place l'accès
aux nouvelles technologies
l'accès aux nouveaux matériels et la de
ce point de vue là le gouvernement ait
véritablement sans réponse ah les cons
avancé regarde maintenant la journée de
mercredi avec votre rubriques préférées
le couac de la semaine
eh bien le couac de la semaine c'est
bien sûr la démission des socialistes de
la commission copé sur l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel public les démissionnaires
qui reprochent au président sarkozy
d'avoir refusé par avance toute
augmentation de la redevance pour
compenser la fin de la pub si tout se
joue à l'elysée pas question pour le ps
de faire de la figuration dans une
commission jugeait alors prétexte le
couac de la semaine sur lequel revient
pour nos nicolas béart moi qui rêve
d'une vision moderne de la politique je
veux dire que dans ce domaine
l'opposition malheureusement n'a pas la
parole et la nouvelle télévision
publique se fera sans eux les six
parlementaires socialistes et
communistes ont décidé de claquer la
porte
selon l'ombre du chef de l'état
planerait un peu trop sur les travaux de
la commission
nicolas sarkozy s'est opposé à une
hausse de la redevance le veto
présidentiel a donc été acté dans la
commission partir du moment où le
commanditaire lui-même celui qui pose
des questions avant même que nous ayons
terminé notre travail apporte lui même
les réponses et fragilise les deux
piliers de deux viols public qui
historiquement sont les ressources
publicitaires d'un côté et la redevance
de l'autre on voit bien la difficulté à
laquelle on est confronté la publicité
du service public ira sur tf1 et m6 ces
chaînes devraient bénéficier d'une
coupure pub supplémentaire
une faveur au privé que dénoncent les
parlementaires socialistes
il y a à peu près 550 millions d'euros
de plus pour secteur privé
la manne du public de la poussée du
public vers le privé
plus les 300 millions à peu près évalué
de la deuxième coupure publicitaire donc
plus 550 millions pour tf1 m6 et les
amis du président
et pour le secteur public - et une
incertitude totale sur les compensations
possible
la suppression de la publicité ces 800
millions d'euros en moins dans les
caisses de france télévisions la
question demeure donc comment financer
le manque à gagner
la commission envisage pour le moment
une taxation des fournisseurs d'accès
internet ainsi que des nouvelles
recettes publicitaires des chaînes
privées
une chose est sûre pour le moment pour
beaucoup d'experts le compte n'y est pas
bruno le roux est ce qu'il va pas être
reproché aux socialistes d'avoir quitté
cette commission copé d'une certaine
manière d'avoir abandonné le navire
escaut l'audiovisuel public par exemple
ne va pas vous reprocher de les
abandonner
non mais en même temps il ne peut pas
être pour nous question d'être caution
d'une histoire qui est écrite à l'avant
cette histoire c'est l'histoire
l'histoire de du groupe bric qui vient
voir le président la république et qui
me dit monsieur le président tf1 ne va
pas très bien il faudrait que cela il
mieux demain parce que nous avons envie
de racheter un groupe qui s'appelle par
exemple areva et de rentrer dans le
nucléaire mais pour ça il faut que nous
ayons un groupe qui soit en pleine forme
aujourd'hui ça va pas très bien mais
doit le public sent que vous étiez
plutôt favorable on d'eiffage
oui c'est une idée et je voudrais
corriger cette unité que les socialistes
avaient au moment où il nous semblait
dans nos textes et elles datent de
plusieurs années que la publicité qui
est étroitement corrélé au contenu des
programmes
or nous nous apercevons aujourd'hui que
dans les modèles économiques des chaînes
et notamment des chaînes publiques
il ya une déconnexion entre la publicité
et le contenu des programmes entre le
financement et donc de ce point de vue
là je demande ici officiellement
président de la république de revenir
sur cette mauvaise idée du retrait de la
publicité sur les chaînes publiques
puisqu'il n'est pas capable d'imaginer
d'autres sources de financement c'est
d'accord avec vous la position de bruno
le roux très bien pensé que nicolas
sarkozy est aujourd'hui en train de tuer
le service public
je pense que nicolas sarkozy ne tue
jamais il donne à ses amis et donc il
est en train de préparer non simplement
la capacité pour le gros bruit pour le
groupe tf1 à pouvoir se remplir mieux
les poches et peut-être à donner à
quelques amis l'audiovisuel public dans
les prochains mois allez un petit tour à
nouveau du côté des institutions avec la
réforme du mode de scrutin du sénat on
en a parlé tout à l'heure le parti
socialiste en a fait un de ces
préalables vote positif sur la réforme
des institutions
eh bien les sénateurs socialistes ont
donc déposé une proposition de loi
visant
modifier le collège électoral des
sénateurs un texte déjà rejetée par
l'assemblée nationale il y a dix jours
et qui a subi le même sort au sénat
mercredi après un débat forcément
passionnés dans l'hémicycle alexandrine
nicolas on est là pour représenter les
territoires par la population la
population cette assemblée nationale
faut-il réformer le mode d'élection des
sénateurs à l'heure actuelle ils sont
élus par une majorité d'élus de
territoires ruraux les territoires de
moins en moins peuplées qui ne
représente plus vraiment la population
française pour la gauche pour que cette
représentation soit démocratique
c'est-à-dire représente bien l'ensemble
de la population
il faut corriger avec les mutations
sociologiques il y a eu et en
particulier la perte d'habitants dhr
dans le milieu rural par rapport à 80%
maintenant qu'ils vivent dans le dans
les agglomérations pour la majorité la
démographie ne doit pas rentrer en ligne
de compte car le sénat doit représenter
l'ensemble des territoires même peuple
et la majorité qui affirme par ailleurs
avoir déjà apporté les modifications à
l'élection des sénateurs modifier le
mode de scrutin
le moment n'est donc pas au portant pour
l'instant non parce qu'on n'a pas
attendu de voir ce qu'allait donner les
réformes comme a adopté il ya deux ans
maintenant qu'il faille peut-être et
nous l'avons fait nous mêmes à notre
propre initiative en 2003 modifier un
certain nombre de choses si on veut tout
à fait bien en discuter mais
certainement pas en tout cas dans un
débat préalable à la réforme de nos
institutions
une réforme des institutions dont
l'avenir reste incertain
la gauche avait en effet posé comme
préalable à sa ratification la réforme
du mode de scrutin des sénateurs c'est
une figure du mitterrandisme qui a été
exclu du parti socialiste cette semaine
l'éviction de michel charasse une
éviction qu'il considère comme un
honneur
le sénateur socialiste a été mis dehors
après un conflit départemental pour la
présidence du conseil général du puy de
dôme
michel charasse a aussitôt rejoint le
groupe des radicaux au sénat selon lui
pas besoin d'être parti socialiste pour
affirmer des idées socialistes tout de
suite son portrait signé lice prayssac
l'état et les collectivités locales
bonjour l'état bonjour les collectivités
locales vous en prie a suivi vous c'est
la science du camp
c'est ça tout va bien on connaît son but
pour les petites phrases souvent
assassine son art de la formule est de
la provocation
michel charasse et son humour
dévastateur toutes les bancs du ps pour
ceux des radicaux non mais je me fais
léger qu'à vous félicite et je vous
félicite et je ne vous félicite pas être
agacé bousculer c'est son credo
certains diront qu'il en fait trop
d'autres apprécient au contraire sa
gouaille et son franc parler même ses
adversaires politiques
c'est un élu républicain qui a le sens
de l'état qui fait primer l'intérêt
général sur les intérêts particuliers il
n'aime pas la démagogie - dans tous très
honnêtement je ne saurais pas vous dire
quels sont les défauts dont on peut
souffrir
j'en connais pas il est quelquefois
excessive verbalement
si vous en voulez un
mais sur le fond quand on a bien gratter
cette carapace français qui a un homme
de fonds ancien député ancien ministre
du budget et conseiller de françois
mitterrand à l'elysée
66 ans dont 44 passé au parti socialiste
l'homme est fidèle à sa commune de
puy-guillaume dans le puy de dôme dont
il est maire depuis 77 à ses idées plus
qu'à la ligne du parti
mais surtout à celui qui l'a accompagné
pendant vingt ans françois mitterrand
sa référence moi je fais mon métier je
le fais sans sectarisme
je suis absolument pas sectaire je
déteste ce hectares et de françois
mitterrand main mais nous a expliqué
qu'en 80 que la pire chose dans la vie
politique dans une vie politique apaisée
et cher où la démocratie fonctionne
normalement c'est le sectarisme
bon j'ai pas parce que vous pensez
telles personnes pensent pas comme vous
que c'est forcément sale type b s'il
éternel mitterrandiste voilà bien la
seule étiquette qu'il accepte qu'on me
colle à aider son exclusion du parti
socialiste michel charasse a craché sur
le parti dont le niveau selon lui ne
dépasse pas celui des trottoirs il a
même ajouté que le parti socialiste ne
parle plus aux français pour leur dire
la vérité
vous allez le regretté michel charasse
non parce que je n'aime pas les francs
tireurs qui comme ça quelques secondes
après simplement une exclusion marcher
sur leurs parties continuent à le
piétiner et donc il y a nécessité
d'avoir qu'elle des choses en commun
pour appartenir à un parti pas
simplement d'être socialiste d'avoir
envie de vivre ensemble et michel
charasse visiblement n'avait plus envie
de vivre avec son parti depuis déjà
longtemps bonne camaraderie socialiste
sans transition passe à la journée de
jeudi une journée dominée par
l'actualité économique
et la bonne nouvelle de la semaine c'est
bien sûr celle concernant les chiffres
du chômage 7,2 pour cent au premier
trimestre un taux qui n'avait pas été
atteint depuis 1983 alors cela traduit
une réelle embellie du marché du travail
mais sera t elle durable et surtout
va-t-on vers le plein emploi c'est la
question de la semaine avec tout de
suite les réponses de thomas raguet et
alexandrine nicolas de moins en moins de
chômeurs depuis 2006 une tendance à la
baisse semble se confirmer
la raison à cela des créations d'emploi
mais surtout un nombre important de
départs à la retraite alors se
dirige-t-on vers le plein emploi que les
économistes fixe autour de 5% on observe
que les moyens qui sont par chômeurs
dans les pays qui sont en plein emploi
sont nettement plus importants que quand
en france et donc il va y avoir cette
question de l'accompagnement qui va être
primordiale mais encore faut-il que l'on
s'accorde sur la définition du plein
emploi pour certains avoir un emploi ne
veut pas forcément dire vivre décemment
pour nous le taux devrait à taux de
chômage et de précarité
elle serait pas de 7,2 mais ils seraient
à deux chiffes assurément et peut-être
pas loin de 14%
mais la tendance à la baisse du chômage
pourrait bien s'arrêter l'eau cdo
annonce en effet un taux de 7 6% pour
l'année prochaine alors bruno le roux
est ce cas il faut quand même se réjouir
de ces bons chiffres du chômage
tout témoin d'abord pour me réjouir des
chiffres je regarde la réalité dans ma
circonscription beaucoup plus de
précarité et il n'y a pas moins de
problèmes aujourd'hui de chômage ne dis
pas que cela explose jeudi qu'il n'en a
pas moins et donc sommes amenés à
regarder les chiffres
ces chiffres je les ai redit
relativement nous sommes pour la
première fois avec plus de 4 % de
premières entrée au chômage et ce qui
fait baisser les chiffres s'est
publiquement des entrées en stage d
entrer en dispositif particulier donc je
constate que de façon mécanique les
chiffres baissent par la démographie
qu'on les fait baisser aussi par des
entrées en stage et que ce faisant on
rejette sur les collectivités locales
qui sont en première ligne
la précarité parce que de plus en plus
il n'ya les gens qui ne travaillent pas
assez pour pouvoir vivre convenablement
même monnaie l'euro quand il ya une
telle décrue est ce qu'on peut
uniquement expliquée sa part du trucage
escarmant un autre vous n'êtes pas
obligé d'expliquer que c'est peut-être
comme quelque part grâce à certaines
actions
non d'ailleurs la france est le seul
pays qui sur un an
perd un peu plus d'un bidule 2 %
d'emplois et nous sommes un des seuls
pays européens
donc je constate qu'il n'y a ni
croissance supplémentaire dans notre
pays une des créations d'emplois qu'au
contraire il ya perte d'emplois et donc
à côté de l'aspect démographique qui
conduisait à une baisse du chômage il ya
surtout une hausse de la précarité parce
que il y a beaucoup d'entrées en emplois
qui sont des entrées en temps partiel
des emplois précaires des emplois et
bien entendu sur le terrain nous le
voyons aujourd'hui de façon démultiplier
ces travailleurs ces gens qui
travaillent ces salariés qui viennent
nous voir en nous disant je travaille et
pourtant je n'arrive pas à payer mon
loyer je n'arrive pas à faire le mois
entier dès le 15 je commence à compter
allez on va maintenant parler des niches
fiscales autres actualités du jour à
l'assemblée après la publication d'un
rapport de la commission des finances
établissant à 486 le nombre de bons
plans fiscaux soit une soixantaine de
niches supplémentaires depuis 2003 pour
didier migaud le président socialiste de
cette commission c'est toujours plus
pour les plus fortunés et ça ne peut
tout simplement plus dur et on écoute ce
que l'on constate c'est qu'on peut avoir
des revenus très confortables
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
plusieurs millions d'euros et échappé en
certaines situations totalement au
paiement de l'impôt sur le revenu donc
voilà nous nous disons qu'il faut non
seulement plafonner la dépense fiscale
par dépenses fiscales mais également
mettre en place un plafonnement global
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne puisse pas
échapper à un paiement d'un impôt sur le
revenu c'est une question de justice
alors didier migaud est là bien dans son
rôle à la fois de président de
commission des finances et de députés
socialistes mais christine lagarde a
l'air de vous avoir plutôt entendu
puisque depuis plusieurs semaines elle
ne cesse de dire qu'elle prend à bras le
corps cette question des niches fiscales
elle augmente comment vous expliquez un
moment donné il puisse y avoir un
discours d'une ministre et que les
finitions as que là il vous semble que
la misère économies effectivement
n'entend pas ça il y a eu trois niches
fiscales trois ou quatre qui ont été
abordés par la ministre et toutes celles
qui sont les plus fréquentes et ce n'est
pas en comptant d'ailleurs celles qui
ont été ajoutées simplement
depuis un an dont kylie a nécessité
aujourd'hui on ne s'était pas tellement
que le problème à la situation délicate
il y avait quand même je me permets de
le rappeler il n'y avait pas par exemple
le paquet fiscal ces 15 milliards
d'euros qui avait été voté pour la
gauche aujourd'hui il n'y aurait pas de
problème fiscal de nice et nous n'étions
pas à la recherche de la moindre
ressource mais je m'aperçois qu'à chaque
fois que l'on veut une ressource
supplémentaire
on l'a soit sur le plus grand nombre de
cotisants c'est à dire sur les gens qui
sont les classes moyennes et les plus
modestes dans notre société mais qu'à
chaque fois qu'il faut aller chercher
les niches fiscales qui favorisent ceux
qui ont le plus d'argent
le paquet fiscal qui favorise ceux qui
sont les plus riches dans notre société
j'ai vu moi pour la région ile-de-france
le paquet qui a été rendu à ceux qui
sont déjà les plus les moins imposées
les plus riches dans notre région c'est
absolument scandaleux
les deux mousquetaires des comptes
publics et bien ce sont jean arthuis et
philippe marini respectivement président
de la commission des finances et
rapporteur du budget chaque année il
passe au crible les comptes des
institutions publiques comme par exemple
l'opéra paris la banque de france ou
encore l'imprimerie nationale jeudi
ils ont vendu leurs conclusions et elles
sont sévères nicolas béart depuis 2001
ils n'ont pas arrêté
c'est à la loupe que les sénateurs
épluchent les comptes publics ceux des
institutions l'opéra de paris la banque
de france ou encore l'imprimerie
nationale
en tout plus de 50 établissements
publics chaque année une augmentation de
2 170 % depuis 2007 nous faisons ces
contrôles pas uniquement dans les
administrations centrales nous allons si
la remise administrations déconcentrées
sur place et qui nous permet à la fin
d'émettre des critiques des
recommandations qui donne lieu à des
auditions publiques à des redressements
et à un suivi pour vérifier si les
recommandations ont été suivies
les fins limiers du sénat travaille de
pair avec la cour des comptes
ils traquent toutes les économies
possibles gage d'une bonne gestion des
comptes publics
nous observons des changements dans
l'organisation des ministères dans
l'attitude prise par tel ou tel ministre
par telle ou telle administration qui
intègre tout ou partie des propositions
que nous faisons nous devons nous
parlementaires nous exonérer et d'un
procès en complicité au
dysfonctionnement de l'état les
parlementaires espèrent beaucoup de la
réforme des institutions pour accroître
encore leur rôle de contrôle un degré de
plus dans le renforcement des pouvoirs
du parlement allait en fini maintenant
la semaine avec la journée de vendredi
et une belle image
la belle image de cette fin de semaine
c'est cette très prestigieuse brochette
de ténors politiques français aux côtés
de nicolas sarkozy ce week-end au liban
pour un message fort de la france au
pays du cèdre après 18 mois de crise
entre majorité antisyrienne et
l'opposition dominée par le hezbollah
les deux parties ont trouvé un accord
qui a permis l'élection du président
sleiman et ce sont rien moins que marie
george buffet françois bayrou françois
hollande et jean pierre raffarin qui
sont avec le président français pour
soutenir à ce pas vers la paix est une
belle image vous avez enfin cesser la
politique bueno l'euro il la politique
qu'elle tels que je vous l'aï dit depuis
tout à l'heure est à faire de différence
d'idées là nous sommes d'accord pour
dire au liban qui lie à la volonté de la
république de toute la république à être
dans un partenariat à un tutorat prince
protectorat mais le fait que les
différentes forces politiques soit avec
le président de la république c'est la
volonté de dire stabilité et aide de la
france pour la construction
quoi qu'il arrive débat au ps pour
savoir si vous deviez accompagné le
président de nom françois hollande a dit
dès qu'il a une invitation il s'est
renseigné pour savoir le cadre qui était
celui ci puisqu'il y avait une sorte
d'improvisation dans ce qu'a fait le
président de la république
vite et les uns ne pas inviter les
autres et donc il convenait d'inviter
tous les partis représentés à
l'assemblée nationale cela a été fait et
donc à partir de là il ne pouvait pas
être question de petites questions de
politique intérieure ça veut dire aussi
qu a pas tant de différences que cela
entre la gauche et la droite sur
certains sujets de politique étrangère
ça veut dire qu'il peut y avoir y
compris sur le liban sur la façon il va
y avoir des débats qui peuvent être des
débats où nous aurons des différences
mais aujourd'hui le liban a trouvé de la
stabilité
il est dans un processus où cette
stabilité doit être confortée et
notamment où il doit trouver delà de
l'appui des zones appui nous voulons
dire aux libanais que la france est
toujours à leurs côtés et pour cela je
crois que le symbole de tous les partis
représentés au parlement avec le
président était un beau symbole
républicain
allez après la politique étrangère doit
maintenant finir la semaine avec la
présidente de coeur bien sûr à défaut
d'être élu carla bruni sarkozy
l'hebdomadaire le point la met en une
cette semaine avec ce titre la
présidente le point qui publie en
exclusivité des extraits du nouveau
livre politico people carla et nicolas
la véritable histoire c'est signé yves
azeroual et valérie bénaïm il y raconte
par le menu la rencontre du couple
présidentiel c'est pipeau la sq à
souhait on sait tout des relations
houleuses avec rachida dati en passant
par les bons conseils de bernadette
chirac et sans oublier la demande en
mariage bref on ne leur ont rien de
fondamental pour la république
mais ça va peut-être ce sera sans doute
même s'arracher comme des petits pains
vous lisez ce genre de livre non je
préfère les livres de bertrand les
livres de martin tous les vivres qui au
parti socialiste dépasse aujourd'hui les
jours et que ségolène mais non savez moi
je n'ai pas voté pour carla bruni donc
je ne la reconnaît pas comme présidente
je n'aime pas la politique qui est faite
par son mari je la conteste même 3 tu
mens il pour autant on se mobilise et
les livres alors notre petit ami du
parti socialiste je lis des livres de
mes amis mais pour finir
vient sortir labrunie je regrette qu'il
puisse y avoir ce type de choses je
trouve qu'elle représente notre pays en
tout cas pour l'instant elle n'a pas
fait de faute à la représenter de façon
dit la france et je ne trouve pas à st
ce genre de livre pour ce qui des
socialistes je voudrais qu'ils
s'occupent peut-être moins quelquefois
de chercher à vendre des livres et plus
de faire en sorte de nourrir
véritablement un débat d'idées à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste on a
quelquefois trop tendance à croire que
leur cohérence ils vont la chercher à
l'extérieur mais qu'ils sont dans des
jeux à l'intérieur et bien françois
hollande a dit posons les idées sur la
table faisant en sorte que chacun dise
d'accord pas d'accord et exprimons nous
peut-être moins avec les livres à côté
plus avec les débats à l'intérieur
merci beaucoup bruno le roux d'avoir
erré avec un simple peut-être la série
c'est une motion d'une famille
merci on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine période même endroit même
heure exactement hebdo nouvel invité à
la semaine prochaine très bonne semaine
à tous
577 enfants relouer à l'assemblée
nationale des écoliers de cm2 qui
viendront dans l'hémicycle pour faire
aboutir la loi qui compte pour eux le
temps d'une journée
découvrez la politique vu par des à 36
députés très impliqué un événement à
vivre en direct aujourd'hui à partir de
10 heures et 14 heures sur la chaîne
parlement